Jacques lolios ne sera plus mère de
Manille et ho à compter du vendredi 21
septembre c'est l'annonce qu'il a faite
à l'occasion du repas qui clôturait le
forum des associations il a également
présenté celui qui lui succéderait à la
mairie Bertrand Ouillon maire adjoint au
logement et à la petite enfance il a la
moitié de son âge 36 ans fa en sorte que
finalement je prépare déjà donc la bon
et que donc t compte donc du contexte
politique donc local ici sur Man m'a
paraî important que donc la personne qui
va me succéder soit connue déjà avant
finalement et non pas donc au moment des
élections de municipales de 2014 je sais
qu'il y a donc au niveau à droite
beaucoup d'appétit pour moi c'est c'est
d'abord un grand honneur alors on y est
pas encore c'est le 28 he mais c'est
c'est déjà un grand honneur et puis je
l'appréhende vraiment avec beaucoup de
calme et de sérénité puisque c'est vrai
qu'on a une équipe une équipe municipale
au niveau de la majorité qui est
particulièrement solide particulièrement
investi une passation dans la sérénité é
loin du climat qui régnait à Mani Lamo
en 1977 quand Jacques lolios est entré
au conseil municipal comme maire adjoint
à l'époque la ville était placé sous
tutelle Jacques lolos devient maire en
83 il cède son fauteuil à la droite
entre 89 et 95 avant de le retrouver
qure mandats en tout le conseil
municipal devrait enteriner le vendredi
28 septembre l'élection de Bertrand
Houillon Jacques lolieuse demeurera
conseiller municipal il a déjà annoncé
qu'il suivrait de près la campagne des
municipales de 2004 en qualité de
président du comité de soutien l'enjeu
est d'importance conserver la ville à
gauche c'est aussi éviter le basculement
de l'agglomération cantinoise à droite
un double challenge pour le nouveau
jeune
prétendant